you ready - yeah I'm putting these less
important expansions I couldn't give you
a word deceptive title but it's it's
true these are less important spaces
which is why so you've been asking me
questions on this you don't need to use
this 20 to remember this the answer is
no because they're less important but
I'll be justifying why that is so the
first time of less importance measure is
the angle results we've already seen
double angled right so that's when
you've got something like say science-u
feet up let's see how your memories
going what's the expansion for sine 2
theta to start to the tune and then sign
a plus B is the mixed-up one right signs
are closer together
so that's why you get sine theta cos
theta okay right in the same way you've
got your double angular's on for mothers
to theta okay which is it's like the
Pythagorean identity instead of cos
squared plus sine squared it's okay now
just keep your mind on that for a second
because we're going to use this result
in a minute to get these half-baked
moves off what do I mean by negative
results well if these are double angles
I'm making twice the angle okay I'm half
egg result of these sine theta up to cos
of theta
what are these in terms of the regular
on single feed on expressions that were
completely so where you get well do some
college first and I'll get you guys to
prove tans later they come from mainly
this extension is important if you
remember they would see other ways to
write the custody expansion okay and
they were based on the fact that we can
swap out these consequence
sentiment for science words and the
consequence of him which one so let's
take this and remember that we can write
it in treatment where I can say a cos 2
theta is equal to first
let's replace the cross squared with
what can I replace close with one -
let's get good so that'll be 1 minus
sine squared then another minus sine
squared pence - - okay you use the same
logic and cos 2 theta is equal to 2 cos
squared yeah
- what if you replace the sides with
instead now well as where is the half
angle business come in so that you're
not to confuse let's just introduce
another pretty room let's have how far
let alpha that's that that equal to
theta which implies that just one food
on will be Alfred - is that okay so how
does it apply them to these two
identities well my two things you will
become an alpha and my one thing you
will become alpha one - this is where
I'm games my hot thing we look right so
the one way is to swing squared so now
if I want a half a the result for is its
force on it I just need to rearrange and
make sign up or to do this subject does
that make sense so I guess I will
succeed let's let's get these two to
swap sides so X cosine squared I have 1
minus cos on that side so it / - they
take square root
/ - and take the square root same logic
applies over here after you get down
through these lines of work you should
be able to say that COS of alpha on -
after you make your substitution
ope yes
so you can check have you builders now I
said to you I was gonna ask you to prove
this on your own okay there's a couple
of different ways you can go about it
right you could use this same approach
and you can try and rewrite you want an
to alpha the double angle result in
terms of sequel outfits right or you can
say aunt Anna feet or two is sine
theta-2 on because they don't you and
see how simplifies out okay so that's
something I want me to take it up but
that's enough these two results are
thinner the hangers-on so sorry cuz yeah
we don't like them because they turned
out to be not that useful this is what I
mean by less important okay when you're
doing real maths like working angles and
functions they don't come up very much
good question
okay now why would it be plus or minus
what would that indicate to you because
it's negative
you've got a reflect angle but not all
the way up to so you somewhere over
there so when you say it's negative that
you're implying something about the size
of alpha or to something we don't
actually know okay so just leaving it as
positive opens up the possibility that
it could actually be somewhere else
depending on what path there is but it's
not saying look I'm slapping a minus
sign in the front
it must be equal to this okay so in
terms of identities this is what good
question okay so there's the half angle
results you don't need to memorize them
that's one of the reasons why I haven't
addressed them okay but I'm showing you
what they are now because they actually
do a pure the shape you might be choose
okay and they're not that hard to get